après deux ans de qu'ovide les attentes
des voyageurs ne sont plus tout à fait
les mêmes bonjour fibre ou à cannes
bonjour merci être là avec nous
fondateur et directeur du guide du
routard ya vraiment une soif de nature
de la part des touristes des voyageurs
volonté comme ça de retour aux sources
quand on part en vacances c'est quand
même pas la fin de tourisme de masse la
volonté de naturel a toujours toujours
existé compte plus aujourd'hui on la
sent de plus en plus on a d'ailleurs
créé une collection vélo qui il ya
quelques années
marcher convenablement et maintenant on
a on n'arrête pas de réimprimer donc
c'est bien la fra et vacances en vélo à
vélo sur toute la france vous savez
qu'il ya la plus grande concentration de
vélo route en france qui sont des
souvent des véloroutes européenne qui
partent vraiment delhaize qui font mille
deux mille kilomètres des finances en
famille et des vacances en famille des
vacances au rythme de la nature on
s'arrête et des petites auberges y aller
les bords de loire qui sont très
célèbres on peut descendre toute la
france ça traduit envie de vouloir
prendre son temps quelque part apprécié
notamment à la nature oui alors c'est
vrai que le vélo c'est une vitesse de
taille humaine c'est à dire que c'est
plus confortable que la marche à pied
alors que la marche à pied fonctionne
aussi énormément mais plus dans des
sites de montagne en bord de mer dans
des sites très très particulier mais le
vélo on a le temps de découvrir
de ne pas trop se fatiguer et surtout de
s'arrêter au bon moment autre carton le
camping haut de gamme qui se développe
alors c'est quoi un camping haut de
gamme et l'idée c'est toujours d'être
proche de la nature on sait le l'alpha
et l'oméga aussi oui alors le camping a
complètement changé d'image par rapport
à il ya 20 ans le côté un petit peu
populaire faut dire avec la pétanque et
l'apéro vous avez un camping haut de
gamme pour nous c'est le symbole c'est
des campings taupiac y sont des petits
chalets de charme en bord de rivière ou
en pleine forêt et c'est pas si cher en
tout cas c'est beaucoup moins cher que
dès que des locations saisonnières vous
êtes dans un endroit absolument
magnifique ce ne sont pas des normes
camping est là vous êtes en contact avec
la nature et sa rallie tous les
suffrages
et surtout les enfants il ya encore une
fois dans les tendances que vous
observez une forme de désamour pour pour
l'avion c'est vrai ça pour les petits
week-ends comme ça de 2 3 jours à
florence ou à prague désamour pour
l'avion c'est faux c'est plus la durée
qui pourrit sondé sur deux week-ends
voilà c'est à dire que les compagnies
low cost qui propose des week-ends de
deux jours là au guide du routard on
sent une désaffection on a toujours
envie de découvrir florence de partir à
venise quand on est amoureux ou
redécouvrir prague mais pas deux jours
et on va s'arranger pour et là c'est une
tendance lourde qui est très importante
on va essayer d'aller dans les mêmes
endroits les mêmes locaux les mêmes
tarifs mais quatre jours et ça c'est
fort après un voyage en train de nuit
qui revient un petit peu au goût du jour
en même temps il ya peu de lits en
france qui font du tram seulement il y
avait jusqu'à présent de ligne et paris
nice et paris tarbes et on sent une
vraie cette appétence c'est une question
du coût ou pas c'est parce que déjà
quand vous prenez un train de nuit dès
que vous êtes dans le compartiment vous
êtes déjà en voyage souvenez vous
peut-être quand vous étiez plus jeune
avec vos parents la découverte une nuit
dans un compartiment c exotique c'est
cocasse c'est vraiment un voyage à part
à part entière c'est pas plus cher que
l'avion et c'est trop long c'est
beaucoup moins polluant et donc la sncf
a compris
ils ont été très réactifs puisque
maintenant il prend ils vont proposer
l'année prochaine d'autres trains de
nuit vous avez déjà par exemple paris
autriche qui traverse donc en une
journée une nuit en train pour arriver à
salzbourg et l'autriche c'est
d'aider des moments un peu
exceptionnelle à des tarifs tout à fait
abordable vous avez d'être admis qu'ils
sont en train de
partir de d'italie et réciproquement et
bientôt vous allez avoir d'être admis
sur l'espagne vraiment c'est quelque
chose que je vous recommande et je suis
ravi nous au guide du routard on est
notre boulot c'est comme au restaurant
on sert d'abord les plats que les gens
aiment bien consommée et je peux vous
dire que le tran huy est devenue
prioritaire promet rédacteurs il ya une
forme ou sinon deux après deux ans de
crise sanitaire de revenge travel pour
certains voyageurs qui ont cette
boulimie de voyage après avoir été
empêchée privé à cause du coc vide où
est-ce qu'ils vont durcir oui oui
c'est un peu le syndrome de la sortie de
prison on a été bloqué et maintenant on
veut en profiter
les gens ont fait des économies non pas
tellement consommer ils veulent en
profiter en partant en voyage dès
l'ouverture par exemple du du marché
américain on a senti un boom on veut re
découvrir les à les états unis qu'on
aime tant en plus ça correspond à la fin
de l'ère trump et bien new york par
exemple est devenue la deuxième vente
actuellement de guide du routard sur
l'ensemble de la collection étrangers
avec des vacances qui sont toujours plus
flexibles plus flexible que jamais parce
que les voyageurs vais pouvoir
finalement annulé en dernière minute si
jamais ils sont malheureusement empêché
de partir c'est devenu maintenant
quelque chose de nécessaire de compter
contournable oui et puis avec des
grandes des grands best of c'est
l'italie c'est l'espagne c'est la grèce
la croatie ça c'est vraiment des
destinations très facile d'accès en une
heure et demie vous à vous y est c'est
relativement abordable il y à des
prestations qui sont très confortables
beaucoup de gens parlent français danser
dans ces pays là et c'est complètement
à la mode et les gens pour être allé il
n'y a pas si longtemps en grèce j'ai été
très surpris du nombre de
français sur les monuments grecque avec
l'idée que certains pays puisqu'on parle
indirectement de tourisme de masse
cherche à éviter à limiter en tout cas
les effets de ce tourisme à grande
échelle sur leur espace naturel il ya
cette volonté de certains gouvernements
jeudi je sais pas de quel d'ailleurs de
réduire mois de réguler encore une fois
ce le flux de touristes alors qu'une
tendance c'est la bonne gestion du
tourisme je vous souhaite un exemple la
descente en radeau du colorado qui est
un grand must américain puisque ça
attire quand même 10 millions de
passagers par an et bien quand vous
prenez cette descente vous ne verrez
jamais aucun autre radeau en avant ou en
arrière alors celle aventure c'est
formidable je suis pratiquement un
pionnier
qui découvre le colorado et bien il ya
une règle parce que le colorado c'est
sur un parc américain et c'est
extrêmement contrôlé lorsque le rameur
le capitaine du radeau remarquer
l'horizon 1
un autre bateau pirate il doit
obligatoirement ralentir il est interdit
de voir à l'horizon à l'avant ou à
l'arrière un autre bateau donc vous avez
le sentiment d'être en découverte date
isolé alors qu' il ya eu des milliers de
passagers qui sont passés de 100 à 100
est de touristes et les ja c'est une
régulation américaines et je peux vous
dire que les rangers qui sont 202 garde
champêtre surveille
vraiment d'une façon très sérieuse et
l'amande il faut la payer aussitôt quand
il ya un déplacement donc il faut s'en
inspirer de ça
pas forcément au niveau de la bande
parce que c'est le côté un peu extrême
des américains mais la bonne le les flux
fermé par exemple et lé parking du mont
saint-michel lorsque il y a une
une
sur
surconsommation sur visite de deux
grands sites ça commence à se faire et
je pense que en france est plutôt
relativement bien régulé avec une
destination star pour cet été qui reste
la france pour les français bien sûr la
france à tout seigneur tout honneur vous
le savez la france plus beau pays du
monde partager car vais voyager partout
où c'est intéressant parce que oui
vraiment je peux vous le confirmer
après avoir voyagé un peu partout la
france est mon pays préféré parce que
c'est le plus éclectique c'est le plus
divers vous allez en bretagne vous allez
découvrir des endroits préservés les
enclos paroissiaux qui sont uniques dans
le monde vous les avez dans le
finistère-nord la cuisine est
extrêmement particulière dans cette
région très différente si vous allez
dans le périgord ou sur la côte d'azur
et donc à chaque région en france c'est
un voyage différent merci beaucoup
philippe lagane donc le fondateur du
guide du routard merci merci m'avoir
invité
[Musique]